meet angel add allaha she's an
epidemiologist and development
consultant who has founded an
organization to boost food production on
a local level
she and her team want to make it easier
for young people to become active in
agriculture by making new technologies
such as hydroponics and containerized
vertical farming available to them we
chose this instead of planting outside
is because number one it helps us to
conserve space so these plants you would
notice that one acre can usually do
about 2,000 heads of lettuce but with
what we're doing here one container
20-foot container which is about 14
square meters it's doing 3,000 heads of
lettuce so you take the bottom row you
now multiply it by four and you get you
know your crops they're method uses 10
times less land ten times less water and
less maintenance yet guarantees 15 times
higher yields then if you look at the
crops as well they if I do it outside
I'm gonna lose a lot of my crops because
of the pests so I'm always afraid that
something's gonna eat my crops we can
see there's not one bite in these plants
she gathers the waste from her poultry
house and dumps it into this compost pit
the resulting solution is added to her
hydroponic systems as fertilizer for
vegetables they also cooperate with
other farmers to help them compete on a
commercial scale as a young person wants
to get into agriculture I found it very
difficult to get access to land I found
it very difficult to get access to water
and all the other things that I needed
to do effective agriculture and even
then you realize that you're not making
as much you're losing your crop so we
started with greenhouses and hydroponic
systems and then we said okay how come
we can't farm inside a container and
retrofit it with a hydroponics system so
we just tried it we've just kind of been
kind of hacking our way through
agriculture and this innovative farming
technology is resilient to climate
change it also helps to recycle these
containers and other locally found
materials
it was something that was helping us to
be more eco-friendly we were cautious of
how much land we're using we didn't want
to go into the bush and clear land and
destroy the forest we wanted to be
cautious about how much water we were
using we didn't want to keep irrigating
the soil and then it just runs off and
then we have to get more water we wanted
to be able to make sure that we're
increasing our yield practie the idea
behind this is to bring fresh quality
produce directly to those who need it
they harvest at least a hundred and
twenty kilograms a month so far eighty
eight companies buy the veggies in large
quantities some individuals order as
well
Food Security poverty and migration are
persistent problems in Nigeria I really
just want to improve my country and add
to my country if I could be using my
brain there I can be using my brain here
so the concept is how do we develop our
own spaces how do we make sure that our
own people have jobs we're not gonna
wait for government to do it we're not
gonna wait for anybody to do it we're
gonna do it ourselves
in the mean time at Elijah has moved on
to the next generation in vertical
farming technology she wants to make
agriculture more attractive to Nigeria's
young people